bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de fès heidi de l'iphone d'ici samedi a
été hacké il est complètement possible
aujourd'hui de déverrouiller votre
téléphone à partir d'un masque on va
regarder si vous courez ce risque on
peut facilement vous voler votre
identité et voir à la fin à qui
s'adresse est-ce que ça craint oui non
voilà on regarde ça pique nique
des acteurs vietnamiens ont réussi à
pirater faille saïdi alors qu'apple a
annoncé son système de déverrouillage de
reconnaissance faciale quasiment
inviolable avec uniquement une chance
sur un million de se faire usurper son
identité est noir mais qu'apprend on se
rend compte très peu de temps après son
annonce et après le lancement que c'est
pas du tout le cas il est très facile
entre pas très facile assez facile
d'usurper votre identité via faith a dit
fayçal dit comment ça marche
c'est assez simple à comprendre fayçal
qui utilise la caméra trop d'elle ce
qu'on retrouve en os de l'iphone 10 sur
la face avant
c'est un scanner à lumière structuré qui
va projeter une lumière infrarouge
directement sur votre visage
la caméra infrarouge par koné de visage
il ya trente mille points différents qui
permettent de modéliser réellement en
trois dimensions votre visage
la modélisation est enregistré dans
votre téléphone donc normalement c'est
inviolable d'ailleurs samsung avait
rencontré ce problème avec son i suite
qui avait réussi à pirater à partir
d'une simple photo celle filât le
système d'apple normalement est
inviolable
alors comment fait cette société
vietnamienne pour réussir à pirater
fayçal
ils ont tout d'abord scanner un visage
créer un masque en trois dimensions du
visage ils ont utilisé pour les yeux et
pour la bouche des photos en deux
dimensions tout simplement découpé au
papier incrusté sur le visage ils ont
créé un nez en silicone donc il suffit
d'avoir du plastique du silicone du
papier décision et du maquillage et dans
l'absolu tout le monde peut vous pirater
votre fils a dit sauf que en réalité
c'est pas aussi simple que ça déjà il
faut pouvoir scanner le visage de
l'individu pendant cinq minutes pour
avoir une vraie connaissance de son
village et de sa structure
alors à moins que vous puissiez endormir
quelqu'un le posez lui faire un plaqué
sur le visage pour vraiment avoir la
forme exacte de son visage ça paraît pas
aussi simple que ça c'est donc vraiment
d'avoir un vrai travail de préparation
c'est à dire avoir plusieurs photos
haute définition de l'ensemble du visage
de la personne que l'on souhaite pirates
et ensuite il faut pouvoir imprimer en
trois dimensions son visage très
exactement bon pour les yeux et la
bouche c'est assez simple le nez en
silicone c'est pareil ça demande un
travail de précision il ya eu deux
versions du masque qui a été fait par
cette société vietnamienne
le premier a coûté à peu près 150
dollars le deuxième 200 $ donc on
imagine qu'on va pas s'amuser à vouloir
reconstituer le masque de monsieur ou de
madame tout le monde
simplement parce que ça a un coût donc
ils sont les gens qui sont
potentiellement piratable je dirais les
gens où on a un vrai intérêt derrière un
intérêt de données pour récupérer les
données du téléphone c'est à dire à brax
et aux e-mails au numéro de téléphone ou
sms à toute la sphère privée
conforterait dans un smartphone
donc on imagine qu'on va pouvoir
chercher à pirater un chef d'état un
patron du cac 40 pour de l'espionnage
industriel
un milliardaire pour chercher à lui
prendre de l'argent des personnalités
connues ou il arrêtait ray derrière donc
en règle générale je ne pense pas que
vous soyez visé à moins que ce soit
monsieur bernard arnault qui sont en
train de regarder la vidéo d'ailleurs
salut bernard ou alors encore emmanuel
macron c'est lui manu ou d'autres
personnalités très connues et très
influente
sinon en règle générale monsieur madame
tout le monde dont je fais partie et
probablement vous faites vous aussi
partie de crédit relativement pas grand
chose mais qu'est ce que ça montre ce
problème qu'est ce que ça montre
réellement
eh ben ça montre que des technologies
qu'on nous annonce comme étant
inviolable le sont réellement pas du
tout il faut toujours être vigilant par
rapport à ces données faire attention où
les stocks comme on les stocke quel
système de sécurité on met en place et
c'est vraiment ça qui est mis en avant
alors la société m n'amène en question
on imagine que bach pour elle ça va
pouvoir lui emmener de la visibilité
pourquoi pas du business ashton rappelle
que coup de fil qui lui sont passés
probablement par des personnes peu
scrupuleuses qui vont chercher à vouloir
créer ces masses et à savoir comment ils
ont fait pour leur produire eux mêmes
mais ce qui est sûr c'est pour nous ça
doit vraiment nous servir d'exemple et
nous fait réfléchir
attention à nos données attention à ce
qu'on en fait et à la sécurité numérique
d'une manière générale dans l'absolu
fayçal y ait quelque chose de sécuriser
pour l'utilisateur lambda on a pour
l'instant je pense rien à craindre
donc on va pouvoir l'utiliser
tranquillement sans avoir peur de nous
faire appliquer toutes nos informations
néanmoins il faut être dit
milan voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur
ce piratage aujourd'hui dites moi vous
ce que vous en pensez que vous craignez
pour la sécurité de votre téléphone est
ce que vous faites confiance au système
de sécurité qui soit le déverrouillage
d'empreintes digitales que ce soir fait
ça dit que ce soit différent système de
reconnaissance faciale
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire on en
discute ensemble quant à moi je vous
invite à blesser un joli pouces vous
invite à vous abonner à ma chaîne
passera toujours toujours toujours plus
de contenu pour parler de nouvelles
technologies du high tech
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo portez
vous bien soyez ça je vous donne rendez
vous très prochainement pour une
prochaine vidéo
ciao